welcome back to new rockstars I'm marina
Mastro's and the marvel cinematic
universe is finally welcoming home the
Fantastic Four that's right
they're booting the for right out of
fant for stick and opening up the MCU to
one of the best superhero teams plus
some of the best villains Doctor Doom
Galactus and Silver Surfer Annihilus and
warren who cares if Philip thinks the
thing looks like poop Marvel head Kevin
Feige has only given us limited details
about his reboot plan saying at Comic
Con I'm extremely excited about those
characters and about bringing Marvel's
first family up to the platform and
level that they deserve Oh Kevin vague
II more like right my god I'm super good
but here's the thing if you've been
watching the MCU films closely there
have actually been a number of clues and
details that could set up the Fantastic
Four's
MCU homecoming I got four theories for
how Marvel has already opened this door
without fans realizing it and of course
spoiler warning in case any of these end
up being right you know somehow paraone
Avengers tower will become the Fantastic
Four's
Baxter building we saw in spider-man far
from home that the former Avengers tower
was going through some remodeling some
have suggested it could be the new
Oscorp building but another theory is
that the new occupants are Reed Richards
Sue Storm Johnny Storm and Ben Grimm in
the comics the Baxter building was the
towering Manhattan headquarters for the
Fantastic Four it was renovated so that
the team could use the top five floors
for all their hero needs and in the MCU
the vacated Avengers Tower is perfect
for what rear itches would need it for
you mean to tell me this place comes
with a hi-tech lab a jet landing pad and
the guy who loved us 3,000 used to live
here I'll take it this would be a great
way to keep the iconic MCU landmark in
the family and give Ben Grimm a fully
stocked bar to get his drinks on the
rocks moving on to theory to the
Fantastic Four heroes are from another
universe that's right we're only on
number two and I went full multiverse no
apologies I'm never sorry for anything
so Avengers end game crack the MCU egg
wide open with a series of alternate
branch realities one in which Loki gets
away another in which cap goes back in
time to marry Peggy and weirdly let's
JFK die what's that about and despite
Mysterio's lies in far from home the MCU
multiverse is still very real and
we'll continue to be explored in Doctor
Strange in the multiverse of madness we
don't really know the rules of
interdimensional travel in the MCU but
you know who probably does Reed Richards
what if the Fantastic Four are
superheroes from another alternate
history but unlike Mysterio their
backstory is actually legit maybe during
Doctor Strange and Wanda Maximoff
multiverse exploration in that film
they'll arrive in a branch reality in
which is fantastic for it not the
Avengers are the team protecting earth
that would be super cool essentially it
would be reality in which Marvel didn't
sell off its most popular characters to
other movie studios you know the good
timeline but of course bringing in the
good guys from that alternate timeline
would also probably open the door to the
[ __ ] sorry like dr. Victor Von Doom
okay what if dr. doom is the villain of
Doctor Strange in the multiverse of
madness the Battle of the docks the
Sherlock and Moriarty of the Marvel
world plank 4d chess the fourth D is for
damn there you three the Fantastic Four
have been in the MCU the whole time in
the quantum realm
one of the biggest loose threads from
Marvel phase three was how they'll did
Janet Van Dyne survived on her own for
so long in the quantum realm she didn't
say much but as she and Hank Pym left
the quantum realm you can barely make
out what looks like a tiny city in the
background which is really cute
the quantum realm is an adaptation of
micro world in the Marvel Comics a place
visited by ant-man and the Fantastic
Four and dr. doom doom shrunk down into
nothing but later was discovered as the
ruler of the subatomic world perhaps
part of Janet's mystery story was
connected to doom or the Fantastic Four
in that quantum realm city racing on
those goofy maggot things of course and
game revealed that the quantum realm
contains time vortexes and enable time
travel Scott Lang went into one of those
so the five hours that he spent in the
quantum realm was actually five years up
here this could connect with ant-man
director Peyton Reed's old Fantastic
Four movie idea in 2003 which would have
set the Fantastic Four in the 60s what
if there were all collaborators with
Hank Pym in the 60s got lost in the
quantum realm slipped into a time vortex
and popped back out in the 21st century
post endgame oh great now everyone's a
superhero it's not just us with the
quantum realm could
we their version of the negative zone
the alternate reality they visit in the
comics that leads me to the next theory
and final one very for samus's snap
radiation affects them in space the way
the Fantastic Four have got their powers
of course in the comics is through
cosmic radiation while on an unpermitted
space flight and endgame notice the way
rocket described fan assists napped when
Dino snapped his fingers earth became
ground zero for a power surge of
ridiculously cosmic proportions no one's
ever seen anything like it rocket then
said that another surge happened again
that was when Thanos to use the stones
to destroy the stones reducing them to
atoms I'm curious what effect that
second shockwave could have had across
the entire universe like a rift into the
negative zone or enhancing the powers of
the Fantastic Four turning one of them
into dried poop those are like Phillips
words so you know tweet at him maybe
these stranded astronauts could be
stumbled upon by guardians of the galaxy
or they could poop out of the devil's
anus on Sekar in a Thor love and thunder
post-credit scene picture it we its neck
stretches out of a hatch is this still
the negative zone seems like I'm just
gonna stay invisible how do you love the
Fantastic Four are introduced into the
MCU comment down below with your
thoughts and theories and subscribe to
new rockstars for more theories about
Marvel's future I'm marina masterís
thanks for joining me and I swear to god
I have not put Eric in a well
[Music]